WITHOUT ANY FURTHER ADO, TIME
FOR TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS.
AMONG SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER'S TEAM NOW EMERGING.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS, WE
HAVE NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT.
PRESS LAST APRIL TO TALK ABOUT
THE INVESTIGATION INTO PAUL
MANAFORT.
THE NEXT DAY THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS RUBBED A MAJOR STORY ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT REGARDING ALLEGED
MONEY LAUNDERING.
THANK YOU PAUL WISEMAN.
SHARE DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION
A LOT MORE ON MEDIA COLLUSION
THAT WE WILL BE HAVING COMING
DAYS.
THE A.P. DENYING THAT STORY.
HERE'S WHAT SHOULD BE CONCERNING
TO EVERY AMERICAN TONIGHT.
DURING THE MEETING WITH
REPORTERS, ANDREW WEISSMAN, THE
NUMBER ONE GUY APPOINTED BY
ROBERT MUELLER, HEAD OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FRAUD
DIVISION, THEN LATER, NOT LONG
AFTER, JOINED MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION TO LOOK INTO PAUL
MANAFORT, THE NEXT MONTH.
ACOURTING TO SARA CARTER'S
REPORTING AEISSMANN TOLD HIS
SUPERIORS ABOUT THE MEETING WITH
THE A.P. AND HE WASN'T WORKING
ON THE MANAFORT CASE AND DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO IT.
HERE'S THE THING, WEISSMANN WAS
MUELLER'S TEAM WHERE HE'S
LEADING THE CASE AGAINST
MANAFORT.
NOW, HE WAS PREJUDGING THE CASE,
PREJUDICED.
MASSIVE CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
WE OBVIOUSLY SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
AND THEN THERE'S WEISSMANN'S
DISTURBING HISTORY.
WHY WOULD ROBERT MUELLER EVER
APPOINT THIS GUY THAT LED THE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE
AGAINST ARTHUR ANDERSEN
ACCOUNTING AND THE ENRON
SCANDAL, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOBS.
THEY'RE OUT OF BUSINESS.
THANK YOU WEISSMANN.
THE SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED A
RULING 9-0 IN THE CASE.
HIS JOB WAS A MESS.
PEOPLE, BY THE WAY, EXCULPATORY
FOUR MERRILL LYNCH EXECUTIVES
BEHIND BARS.
YOU MIGHT NOT CARE BUT GUESS
WHAT, THEY WERE INNOCENT,
CONVICTIONS OVERTURNED BY THE
FIFTH U.S. CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEARANCE.
YOU WOULD CARE IF IT WAS YOUR
FAMILY.
NO, HE KNEW IT, THEY'RE BEST
FRIENDS.
MUELLER CAN'T MIND MEMBERS OF
HIS INVESTIGATION DONATED
TRUMP.
THIS IS POLITICAL BIAS.
THIS PROVES THE INVESTIGATION
HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES TO BE A
LAW.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TONIGHT, WHY
I AM SAYING, ANDREW WEISSMANN
NOT ONLY NEEDS TO BE FIRED BUT
FULLY INVESTIGATED.
AND ROBERT MUELLER HAS A LOT OF
EXPLAINING TO DO, ABOUT HIS TEAM
DISBANDED.
WHY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL NEEDS TO
BE SHUT DOWN ONCE AND FOR ALL.
AND, NO, THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
NEED TO ANSWER ANY OF THEIR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT'S SO
FUNDAMENTALLY CORRUPT.
MUELLER'S PARTISAN PROBE, PART
OF A HANDFUL OF LAWMAKERS
INTERESTED IN THE TRUTH, ASKING
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SCREEN.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, WILL SCROLL
ANSWERED.
I URGE YOU TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
AT THESE.
WE'LL BRING IT UP LATER.
THE DOSSIER, THE BASIS FOR
SECURING THE FISA WARRANT TO SPY
ON A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY.
AND ON A PRESIDENT-ELECT.
WHY WON'T THE FBI SHOW CONGRESS
THE FISA APPLICATION?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
WE JUST LEARNED LAST WEEK,
ASSOCIATIONS TELLING ME, THAT AT
FIRST THE FISA WANT WAS DENIED
TO SPY ON MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
OVER THE TOP AND GOT THE FISA
WASHED.
DID THE FBI VALIDATE AND
CORROBORATE THAT DOSSIER.
A CLINTON SUPPORTER DID.
HOW DO YOU TRUST THEM?
THE SAME QUESTIONS WE'VE BEEN
ASKING.
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR IT.
ONE OF HER SUPERINTENDENT,
CORRUPT, CARTEL FRIENDS VERIFY
IT?
A KEY PART.
NONE OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH
HILLARY CLINTON'S E-MAIL SERVER.
THIS IS JUST THE 18 QUESTIONS ON
ONE THING.
IT'S ONLY ABOUT THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA DOSSIER.
LET'S SEE, WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
POLITICIZED, WEAPONIZED
AMERICA'S POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE.
THEN THEY WERE SPYING ON AN
OPPOSITION PARTY, DONALD TRUMP.
AND WHAT IS BEING EXPOSED IS A
MASSIVE ABUSE TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
WE WILL HAVE MORE WITH MARK
RELEASED TESTIMONY, SIMPSON
CLAIMED THE FBI HAD A HUMAN
SOURCE INSIDE THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPED
CORROBORATE ASPECTS OF THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
TURNS OUT SIMPSON WASN'T
ACCURATE IN HIS TESTIMONY.
OH, LIED?
FUSION GPS HAS SINCE ATTEMPTED
TO CORRECT THE RECORD NOW BY
SAYING THERE WASN'T AN FBI MOLE
INSIDE TRUMP TOWER.
WAS THERE OR WASN'T THERE?
IT WAS FORMER TRUMP ADVISOR,
THEY SAY, GEORGE POP DOP LOUSE.
THAT WAS BLOWN OUT OF THE WATER
F YOU BELIEVE THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" STARTED THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION BY GETTING DRUNK
AND THEN RUNNING INTO -- RUNNING
HIS MOUTH TO AN AUSTRALIAN
THEN THE DRUNK GOSSIP, YOU HAVE
TO BELIEVE, MADE IT TO FBI AND
THEY REPORTEDLY THEN USED IT TO
START THE INVESTIGATION.
OH, FOUR LEVELS OF HERE SAY.
ALL THE FBI NEEDS TO DO TO
INVESTIGATE A POLITICAL PARTY
DURING A CAMPAIGN, TALK TO A
DRUNK GUY AT A BAR.
WEIGH NEED ANSWERS TONIGHT.
FINALLY THE UPDATE ON THE
URANIUM 1 SCANDAL THAT NO ONE
ELSE COVERS.
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES HAVE NOW
ANNOUNCED AN INDICTMENT IN THE
RUSSIAN BRIBERY SCHEME CONNECTED
TO THE DEAL THAT GAYE RUSSIA AND
PUTIN 20% OF AMERICA'S URANIUM
SUPPLY, WE HAVE SHORT SUPPLY OF.
FORMER COMPANY EXECUTIVE MARK
LAMBERT IS BEING ACCUSED OF
MONEY LAUNDERING, WIRE FRAUD FOR
ALLEGEDLY BRIBING A RUSSIAN
ENERGY OFFICIAL IN AN EFFORT TO
SECURE THE STIPPING CONTRACTS WE
HAVE INFORMED YOU ABOUT ARE SO
IMPORTANT.